compétent mais je peux l'adresser dans
des services spécialisés
sachez cette personne elle a commencé à
agresser ma secrétaire devant la salle
d'attente archipeline et il a agressé en
traitant de transphobe ma secrétaire
bien entendu à la réagi elle ne sait pas
laisser faire alors et enfin il annonce
qu'il va déposer deux plantes
devant la justice il y aura une plainte
contre cette personne qui a insulté
agression vous allez porter plainte
vous-même il y en a deux plaintes qui
vont partir contre la personne qui a
agressé ma secrétaire et une deuxième
plainte contre la personne qui s'est
saisi du dossier sur les réseaux sociaux
et qui a donné mon nom donc nous avons
les informations et des plaintes vont
être lancés dans ce sens alors moi
j'appelle ça en fait vider le sens des
mots pour leur faire dire autre chose
moi ce monsieur je l'ai appelé pour voir
il a refusé de me dire Madame il m'a dit
Monsieur donc on est quand même et il
dit qu'il est pas homophobe alors qu'on
parle pas du tout d'homosexualité
puisque l'homosexualité c'est le c'est
l'identité amoureuse on parle d'identité
de gens donc ça n'a aucun rapport donc
là l'idée c'est de se dire comme je suis
médecin et que j'ai un certain je suis
supposé être très coûté par les gens on
va inverser ça et du coup on va faire
croire que c'est moi qui était agressé
et je vais porter plainte ça tout le
temps moi je pense que ce que vous venez
de faire là il nous le dit ça s'appelle
du drop shining c'est à dire que
en fait vous auriez très bien pu quelque
part régler cette affaire entre
guillemets
sans avoir besoin d'en faire une
publicité
de langage je veux dire elle n'aurait
pas dû le faire savoir publiquement pour
voilà c'est encore une fois il y a des
gynécologues qui sont vous l'avez dit
vous-même
que vous disiez vous
c'est à dire que
vous présente la même personne ça veut
dire que vous vous représentez tous les
mâles 6 blancs qui sont à la table
justement c'est insupportable cette
façon
en fait ça veut dire que dès l'instant
où on prend une position on est vu comme
un facho des transsexuels un facho des
musulmans un facho de je sais pas quoi
il y a un moment donné où a arrêté avec
ça on doit pouvoir débattre et
normalement je suis désolé je
m'interroge sur pourquoi cette femme va
voir un gynécologue dont elle sait que
finalement il va pas mais on ne le sait
pas là maintenant je vous arrête tout de
suite
tu m'avais dit tout à l'heure qu'il y a
des gynécologues qui sont référencés qui
sont spécialisés
c'est que quand un docteur ne sait pas
en fait quand il ne se sent pas
compétents c'est un droit de retrait
dans le loi dans le nouveau coupé pas
s'il vous plaît dans la loi il est
supposé en fait renvoyer vers un
confrère qui lui est spécialisé mais moi
je l'ai non il l'a pas fait on s'est
renseigné mais bien sûr aujourd'hui avec
le recul parce qu'il est attaqué parce
qu'il est attaqué justement
on ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé
concrètement pour le coup je me suis
renseigné
je suis en train d'essayer de vous dire
est-ce qu'on le sait s'il y a de
l'agresser ou pas tu as vu un tweet tu
as vu un tweet de ce médecin
c'est pas parce que il y a des trucs
sexuels qui juste un truc tous les deux
là vous allez utiliser plusieurs fois
transexuel je vous ai envoyé une note
tout à l'heure je voulais dire c'est un
mot qu'on utilise plus depuis plus de
pour les personnes transgenres avant
qu'on utilisait je vous ai envoyé cette
note pour vous dire de surtout pas alors
qu'est-ce que faire attention on
transgenre et ben voilà mais vous n'êtes
pas débile quand même vous l'avez eu
cette mauvaise en plus il y a tous les
deux vous utilisez transexuels il y a
l'étrange genre sympa agréable et poli
comme nous tous il y a des transgenres
qui sont désagréables qui peuvent
un peu le bazar et ben peut-être que
cette personne elle faisait partie des
transgenres qui foutent le bazar et
comme par hasard je peux je peux être
comme ça et puis je peux aussi faire des
conneries bon bah alors c'est pas parce
qu'elle est transgenre qu'elle est
parfaite non plus cette dame par contre
vous faites depuis tout à l'heure ce que
vous faites depuis tout à l'heure c'est
que indirectement vous influencez dans
le dans le dans votre manière de parler
le fait que cette personne pourrait être
comme ça et ce pauvre médecin
évidemment il y a une violence morale de
la part de ce médecin il le reconnaît il
s'en excuse sinon il passe parce que le
mot est horrible et c'est le serment
d'Hippocrate dans l'emploi de
l'hypocrite le mec il va à la radio il
dit non non mais je suis pas je suis pas
je suis pas homophobe déjà ça n'a rien à
voir on a raison on est sur les gens pas
sur le sexe et il a vraiment dit ce
message il a vraiment écrit ça il a
écrit monsieur volontairement j'aimerais
qu'on ait Guillaume après
comprenez-vous sa décision 90% de oui
merci Olivia d'avoir été ajouté une
chose juste en fait c'est il y a un
moment moi que l'année de ma transition
en fait j'ai reçu plus de 200 agressions
physiques sexuelles et viol plus de 200
dans la même année donc c'est quelque
chose qui nous arrive constamment donc
d'entendre quand il y a une personne
trans qui se dire de taper du poids en
disant je me suis fait agresser et que
d'un coup les gens viennent à la défense
en me disant peut-être que cette
personne était violente peut-être vous
faites exactement pareil que quand les
femmes se sont faites violées et qui ont
des gens il faut arrêter qu'elle était
malade
je ne je trouve que votre agressivité
est insupportable depuis tout à l'heure
je pense que tout le monde vous respecte
sur ce plateau et parce qu'on a le
malheur de dire transgenre parce qu'on
n'est pas au courant un coup c'est
on se transforme en transphobe pour moi
les mots ont un sens transphobie c'est
la détestation des personnes trans et le
mépris des personnes trans ce n'est le
cas de personnes autour de ce plateau
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un ce n'est pas le
cas je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui est
peut-être un peu âgé un peu paumé avec
tous ces nouveautés mais qui a du mal à
s'adapter et ce ne sont pas des
consultants vous le connaissez c'est ça
qui est fascinant et parce que ça c'est
vous qui est agressif pas lui je l'ai eu
au téléphone
merci merci à tout de suite on se
retrouve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]